your environment is keeping you where
you are your environment has been
perfectly designed to keep you exactly
where you are right now the people you
listen to the media that you consume the
habits that you do daily all of them are
designed to keep you exactly where you
are so if you want to raise your game if
you want to raise your life you need to
raise your environment I've changed a
lot over the course of having this
YouTube channel the people who've known
me the best and the longest especially
in the past two to three years I've said
Evan you've changed a lot for the better
you've evolved you're more confident you
have more more Poise you're a better
speaker you're pushing the boundaries
more you've changed what happened how do
I get that for myself whenever you are
off growing and learning and evolving
other people they want it they want a
taste of it they want to do it too
because we are not designed to just
photocopy Our Lives over and over and
over again I feel like I have garyvee in
my head I have Oprah Winfrey in my ear
I've got Elon Musk tell me what to do
pushing me to try to get
get a mentor hey it's Nina Carmichael
and we made these videos probably
because you're the most ambitious person
in your circle but you know you're
capable of much more and you get that
Push by surround yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best my husband Evan Carmichael and
learn how to stop keeping yourself poor
enjoy
I hear these people talking about you
have to be courageous you have to be
bold you have to believe in yourself
more and when I feel myself being
nervous about something boom boom boom
boom boom it's a push that I have to do
it
and so I've designed my life I've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step
and it's it's scary and it should be
where am I going next I don't know I'm
still a work in progress but the more
that you are around people who push you
who make you better who make you want to
do more who pull you up to their level
guess what the more you're gonna get
there the alternative is you're stuck
where you are you stick with your
friends you stick with the media you
consume you stick with the habits that
you have and listen if you love your
life awesome if you're good then you're
good then then
don't change anything but if you're not
happy with where you're at if you know
you're capable of more especially for
the entrepreneurs you know you're
capable of more you know you have a gift
you know you're a genius you know what's
in here needs to get out there can have
a huge impact and help a lot of people
if you feel like that's you then you
need to make a drastic change to your
environment you need to change it
because everything you're doing right
now is keeping you on the path that
you're on maybe there's been some growth
if you look at who you were five years
ago compared to now you've grown if
you're watching this channel you've
grown right you've made some changes but
is it drastic enough like are you proud
of where you're at look at where you've
come from in the past year two years
five years are you proud of where you're
at and are you comfortable with that
same level of growth for the next five
years if not if you think I want more I
want to help faster I want to have a
bigger impact faster quicker then the
fastest way to do it is to change your
environment so if that's you I'm going
to give you a three-step process that I
think will help step number one is cut
out negativity just just hide out the
people who don't serve you sometimes
those are friends that you've had from
kindergarten or high school or
university
you're in the Friendship out of
convenience now there's a lot of people
who you might need to let go of you
might need to just let them go They
don't serve you anymore you've you've
walked your parallel path together and
now they've gone out well they probably
just stayed here while you've gone out
here
They don't serve you anymore and it
doesn't mean you have to be a mean
person or cold or rude you're just not
on the same path anymore and a lot of
people fight that because you're worried
about finding new friends or being
around new people and so you stick with
these people who don't serve you anymore
and that's a mistake because they're
keeping you where you're at because
they're negativity they're complaining
their unwillingness to change their
pessimism their laziness they're not
chasing down goals that that becomes
toxic even if you're trying to be a
beacon even if you're trying to be the
person who pulls everybody up
if all you're doing is trying to pull
other people up and there's nothing
pulling you up
you're going to be limited for life
when I went to the Tony Robbins event
the second one where he invited me to
come as his guest
at the end of the first day or second
day you're asked to go do a fire walk
and the whole idea is to do something
scary well I went home to my Airbnb at
the time and and I did the scary thing I
didn't I skipped the fire walk at Tony's
event to go home and do the real fire
walk which was letting go of some people
that that I had been around for in some
cases a decade plus that this doesn't
serve me anymore I'm I'm doing this just
out of convenience instead of something
that's actually helping me grow and so I
need to shed this skin so that I can be
reborn like this is new skin none of you
that's trying to grow
right you're trying to become a
butterfly
but you're forced to stay a caterpillar
you don't want that so you gotta let go
of the negativity sometimes that might
be family and with family maybe maybe
you should cut out some of your family
members from your life maybe maybe
that's that sounds drastic but maybe you
should a less drastic version of that is
just don't talk about some things limit
access if you know that career talk is
always going to cause problems with your
family then don't talk about your career
say I don't I'm not talking about that
and stand up for yourself
at what point is this your life this is
your life your parents your the people
around you they love you they want you
to have success they just they're from a
different era they're a different
generation they don't know what's even
possible right now
what they did if you're 21 their life at
21 was totally different your parents
life when they were your age was totally
different
they don't understand what's available
right now and so even though their
messages is out of love likely like your
parents probably love you
they just don't understand what's
possible
and you can't blame them
this is your fault now you need to
accept responsibility for where you're
at and limit the conversations limit
exposure cut out the negativity from
your life it's really hard for a seed to
grow when it's in a toxic waste dump
and that becomes a choice you know a
seed where it gets planted doesn't
really get the choice of where it gets
planted but you you get to choose you
get to change your environment so choose
powerfully and cut out the negativity
from your life step number two is then
seek out optimism seek out positivity
seek out things that make you grow that
make you want to learn that make you
want to push yourself right I have my
channel that's really helped me that
every day I wake up and I'm surrounded
by positivity and optimism and belief
and things that drive me forward that
even if I've I've had a rough sleep or a
bad day or or whatever it might be I see
Steve Jobs right next to me staring me
down I have my parents behind me looking
at me encouraging me putting belief back
in me I've got videos to go to that will
build me up I've got my believe playlist
of music that I listen to that will
change my state and bring me back to a
place of optimism positivity what is it
for you
is it people do you need to be around
people physically can you go to meetup
groups can you go to the library or
coffee shop can you go join some
entrepreneur circles can you become a
part of a co-working place can you be
around people
that that are positive that are
energizing for you or can it be your
physical environment right or can it be
your habits and your routines or can it
be the the media you consume what are
you consuming what are you watching on
TV
or on Netflix is it is it entertainment
are you just shutting off your life to
try to forget about your problems and
just be entertained or you're trying to
educate yourself to build a better life
this is this is one of the fundamental
problems in the world right now people
they have problems you have problems
most people choose entertainment as a
way to forget about their problems
instead of Education as a way to make
their problems better do you want to
shut off the world
and and laugh at somebody else's expense
and watch big brother and see man that
person's life sucks
or do you want to go build a better life
for yourself
most people don't want to do the work to
actually build a better life I hope that
you do because that's how you actually
end up being happy do you want to numb
it with drugs do you actually want to
build a better life for yourself and in
Step number three is scheduled for
success
schedule for Success so what are your
daily habits what's in your calendar
what is the thing that makes you feel
bold alive contagious you know optimism
what's the thing for me it's watching
videos for me it's going through my 5S
schedule so I start the day with singing
where I have videos that are on YouTube
that just their songs that make me want
to sing make me want to dance make me
want to move it's the fastest way to
change your state I wake up tired and
maybe low energy and then I put on music
and it and it changes my state and makes
me happy do that for yourself don't put
on music that matches your current mood
put on music that matches the mood that
you want to feel like and it's the
fastest way to just in a snap be able to
change yourself we all have music that
makes you bounce and come alive start
your day with that right that's part of
mine so singing then Sun I like getting
Sun uh going outside being in nature
just having sun on my face not just
being stuck inside all day especially in
the morning makes a big difference my
third s is sore so I want to do
something makes me feel bold and come
alive and for me where I love my phone
here but for me I share a message I want
to share a message you want to feel like
the work that I do has meaning and
importance so I think about somebody
that I helped yesterday and then I share
a message on Instagram and Snapchat and
put it up that helps me soar what do you
need for yourself then I sweat so I'll
do a quick workout and then I do
something to scare myself right now it's
doing
um cold showers so I sweat and then I
take a cold shower and it's like and I
do difficult things that's my morning
routine right I called the five five and
a half s rule because
some days I'll start with a snuggle with
my wife in bed so we're seeing if that's
going to become like a 6S protocol but
at least it's five and a half right now
that's what makes me come alive you
might need something totally different
I'm okay with that that's amazing maybe
you need to meditate maybe you need to
pray maybe you need to pet your cat what
is the thing that you need to do to make
you feel bold and alive and and then
schedule that in so that you're not
hoping one day that something happens
you're not hoping that you're gonna meet
the right person or hoping you're gonna
find the right video like demand
Excellence from yourself demand
positivity and optimism from yourself
every day because if you did if you were
bold coffin optimistic positive every
morning if you created that system for
yourself man what could you accomplish
in a year can you imagine
if you did something every morning that
made you feel bold and confident if you
felt bold and confident every morning
for the next year imagine the life and
business that you're gonna have it's
crazy it's wild right so you have to
create that you have to schedule for
success success will come from your
habits so look at your calendar what are
your habits and if you did these habits
would it lead to you becoming a success
rule number two learn to reframe if you
change how you feel about something you
change how you act the problem is most
of the time we don't catch our feelings
if you're feeling negative angry
frustrated depressed it doesn't matter
what the thing is that you're trying to
accomplish you're not going to give it
your all and you're not going to get
results because of your negative
emotional state if you don't start
changing how you feel you're never going
to make progress on the goals that you
set for yourself so one of the things I
love doing whenever faced in a negative
situation is say it's the best it's the
best I'm wearing this hat says Fanta
because friend of the channel Mark
Drigger pointed out to me when I was
saying it's the best that I'm a reframer
I'm reframing I've never heard of the
concept before reframing means you take
this negative situation and then you
spin it you reframe it so that it's
positive so that it motivates you so
that's exciting so that it pushes you
forward instead of it being a negative
thing that is all encompassing and
depressing and brings you down and he
said well you're always positive because
you're just a reframer and it he has his
anagram and I'm a number six or
something I don't know he can give you
more details you want to know what
number you are and what it means go
follow mark.jig on Instagram and ask him
but I don't think that's something
that's just in me I think everybody can
learn how to do it everybody can learn
how to reframe you take whatever
negative situation that's in front of
you and say this is the best right now
this is the best where this came from
was I was on an airplane from Vancouver
to Los Angeles and that's a five hour
flight give or take and I have to sit
next to this really smelly dude and
there was no other option I had to stay
on the plane I had to make my flight I
had to speak at this event the only
other option was get off the plane
and it was really smelly I'm sure he
didn't want to be smelly I'm sure that
wasn't his you know intention or
ambition it just happened probably had
three stopovers you know I hadn't
showered in in however long and just
he's stuck and in my head I'm trying to
find Solutions there's no Solutions and
so I'm upset I'm complaining you know
the 15 seconds of back and forth this
sucks I can't believe it and then here's
what happens in my head I say this is
the best this negative thing that's in
front of me right now this is the best
this is my chance to show myself what
I'm made of right and so he's sitting
right here next to me I'll look over
and just breathe it in
breathe that in breathe in that smell
breathe it in
to show myself
that this is not the limit
that this one dude is not going to ruin
my day and I feel great now about myself
because self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things and I just did
something difficult and that's where
it's the best came from it was a it was
a quick trigger to myself to say this is
the best it's the best and now it's
become this thing that any time I'm
facing a really negative situation that
feels overwhelming and possible just
want to complain find somebody to blame
and say it's your fault no this is the
best this is my change to show myself
and the world what I am made of and so
you can flip it for yourself what is so
overwhelming so impossible so crazy that
is bringing you down you look at your
calendar you look at your list of emails
and it's just depressing great this is
the best if you believe like I believe
that your purpose comes from your pain
if you believe that the thing that you
struggled with the most in life becomes
your calling for the rest of your life
the time that you struggled and suffered
the most as a human your your purpose
for the rest of your life is to help
other people who currently are who you
used to be then that thing that happened
that that massively negative thing the
most painful moment in your life
actually is the best
because it's going to allow you to serve
hundreds thousands maybe millions of
people through your purpose so that
negative things in front of you tell
yourself it's the best so how can you
start reframing I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is just lead with
it's the best look at the problem that's
in front of you right now and ask
yourself how is this the best how is it
the best even though it sucks it's
negative it's impossible whether it's
some small thing like somebody cut you
off on a street or there's a big
snowstorm outside how is it the best how
is this your chance to rise up and show
yourself What You're Made Of just make a
list like write it down right now what
is the big problem in front of you and
how can it be the best step number two
is tell yourself that this is just a
warm-up this is just a warm-up this
thing that is impossible and all scene
and feel
and feels the warm up and this works
whether you're actually lifting weights
like the guy here on my shirt is if
you're in if you're lifting weights and
you feel like you've only got one more
you know rep in you and you tell
yourself this is just a warm-up you know
what you can really go just a couple
more and that's how you actually will
build your muscle that's how you
actually get out of your comfort zone
it's how you actually grow and scale and
stop sitting in your bubble because
here's here's the problem if you think
that this thing that that is
all-encompassing this big problem that
is that is weighing you down and is so
depressing that thing if that's the most
you can handle then you can't do more
and I think you can do more I tell
myself I can do more I tell myself that
this big problem that feels impossible
is just a warm-up that this is not the
boundary of my capabilities that I am
capable of so much more and it's a
fantastic reframing technique that will
trick your mind try it try it right now
try to think of the thing that feels
impossible
that you want to give up and just tell
yourself this is just a warm-up I'm
capable of more and see if it doesn't
give you just a little bit more energy
to go off and solve that problem and
step number three is sing one of my
favorite things to do every morning is
sing it's part of my morning routine I
put in a song that makes me come alive
the fastest way to change your state the
fastest way to go from being negative
and and out of control and depressed to
positive optimistic and happy is the
same is to put on music music is the
fastest way to change your state here's
what most people do we put on a song for
how we currently feel if you're feeling
low depressed angry you'll put on low
depressing angry songs don't do that it
keeps you where you are instead put on
music for how you want to feel put on
songs there's no magic song right
there's no one magic song for me right
now in my morning routine I'm putting on
my own rap I made a rap uh I have a
there's a Chinese song and I'm doing an
English rap on top of it and I love that
song and I love my rap and so it's three
minutes something that I listen to every
morning every morning and I have it on
and I'm wrapping with myself and I'm
dancing it makes me move that song makes
me move right you might listen to it and
hate it awesome but there are some songs
that even if you were tired if you're
feeling lazy if you're feeling low and
this song came on you would have to move
you may not get up and go crazy but if
you're really low and this song came on
you would find yourself singing you
would find yourself moving those songs
that's what you want to start your day
with put it in your daily routine and
the next time you ever feel yourself
feeling low energy put on the songs that
make you come alive quick story about
the rap we were last weekend going to
Costco and being stuck in traffic the
things that I hate the most right in
terms of day-to-day life shopping at
Costco and being stuck in traffic for me
are are tilters I hate it
first world problems right
and so we put on the song
put on my rap song and all of a sudden
now I'm singing to it I'm dancing we're
dancing in the car we're having a great
time just because of one simple song and
so you can use it's the best you can use
this is just a warm up and then put
music on build a playlist today the best
thing you do is build a playlist right
now of 50 songs that you love that if
they came on would would cheer you up so
that you don't have to wait until you're
depressed and low or negative energy to
then go and find the song because in
that window of trying to find the song
You're Gonna abandon it make your
playlist today and whenever you're
feeling low put it on also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
to work designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three take
accountability it may not be your fault
but it's your responsibility it's not
your fault that you were born broke but
it's your responsibility to fix it it's
not your fault that you had no education
but it's your responsibility to learn it
it's not your fault that you had no
connections but it's your responsibility
to make them it may not be your fault
but it's your responsibility and the
sooner you accept that the sooner you're
gonna win so I recently posted to my
YouTube Community tab a quote about
momentum I think people don't have
momentum and I think the path to get
momentum is to do work for free for
ideal clients until you can prove your
value and then they pay you so here's
what I wrote I wrote If you have no
momentum no traction no clients and
start for free prove your worth and
build momentum give them something they
can't wait to have again and pay for
this time hashtag believe and every time
I writes as always sends a great
positive feedback but but this time
somebody wrote a kind of negative
comment and so I wanted to read it
because it's highly applicable in this
video he said Kitsch I don't know about
some of your advice everything is my
fault and work for free to which I reply
yes when you Embrace those two you'll
start questioning your goals it's a hard
message to to take on right whether
everything is your fault everything is
your responsibility where you are right
now it's not about beating yourself up
it's not about saying I suck and I can't
get out it's saying listen this is what
happened to me that's the past the past
doesn't have to equal to the Future
everything that I was born into and and
the circumstances that I grew up with
they don't have to be where I go going
forward look at all your Heroes look at
the people who've made huge inroads
change the world the people that you
look up to and aspire to be like very
few of them were born super wealthy most
of them had a worse upbringing than you
did and they could make it so why can't
you you're just locked in your story too
many people are locked into their story
they're not taking responsibility
they're not saying this is my my problem
to get out of
I wasn't put here right you've been
drafted into a war that you did not
start you were put here
and you have to survive and then you
have to learn to thrive and it's that
decision that you are in charge that
you're responsible that if you go to the
mirror and you say why am I not
achieving my goals why am I not further
ahead
as long as you're blaming somebody else
that might keep you comfortable
keeps you comfortable it means you don't
have to do anything right you're not
winning because your mom you know hit
you you're not winning because your dad
never supported you right you're not
winning because the school system sucks
as long as it's somebody else to blame
it's it's comforting and everybody else
around us are doing the same thing
nobody's taking accountability
everybody's saying it's somebody else's
fault right of course it's not your
fault that you're losing because then
you have to do something about it and
even if you're not losing you're not
hitting the goals as hard as you should
and it's so much easier to put the blame
on somebody else and say well
it's the person's fault well really it's
a person in the mirror it's you it's me
I am not further ahead in my business on
my YouTube channel not because of the
YouTube algorithm
not because my team didn't deliver the
Right video on time me I'm the problem
it's my fault it's my responsibility
right I have to go fix it I created this
mess it's not a mess it's amazing but
I'm not a 10 million subscribers
because of me
it's not that people don't want to watch
the content and people don't want to be
inspired
it's me I need to get better I need to
improve and and even if it wasn't my
fault just taking that on
gives you hope that you can change it as
soon as you start putting not even the
blame I think blame is not I don't think
blame helps I don't care who's to who to
blame I care how do we fix it right if
there's a problem that happens in my
business not like who screwed up I don't
care who screwed up I care what are we
gonna do to make sure that we can get
out of this hole and then it doesn't
happen again the next time right taking
personal accountability for where you're
at if you have not hit your goals this
is good news you can
but nobody's coming to save you
nothing's gonna magically change around
you you you're the change you will make
the change you can go make it happen
if I want to grow my business bigger I
need to accept that I need to grow
bigger me personally Evan Carmichael I
is my fault is my responsibility I am to
blame
and use that as a kick forward to say
great like at the beginning that may
suck say oh man I've wasted how many you
know weeks months years going down the
wrong path just casting
blame on other people realizing now it's
my fault okay what can you do about it
now you can change it like at the start
the reality the realization sucks but
then it's also the greatest thing of all
time if you're coming out of
from under the Rock and realize oh my
God this is all my fault
that gives you the power to fix it
because as long as you're relying on
somebody else to do something and they
don't show up you can constantly blame
them but you're never growing you never
accomplish anything because you're
waiting for them you have to wait for
anybody
it's just you and you can fix it you
have the strength you have the power
you're Michael Jordan you have the
abilities you have the skill set and if
you don't have it yet you can develop it
you can acquire it because your Heroes
did it and you can too
so how do you do it I'm gonna give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is accept
responsibility for where you're at just
say I'm here because of me
accept the responsibility don't beat
yourself up don't say wasted however
many years in the same spot but this is
your responsibility now
that where you're at right now is a
result of everything that's happened to
you and the choices the decisions that
you have made even if other people have
negatively impacted you in some way
it's still your responsibility now to
fix it that you can change it just
accepting responsibility without the the
burden and the the pain of feeling like
you wasted a whole bunch of time right
it's a clean slate we're starting over
however old you are great you're
starting you're starting fresh
and you get to create the next two
decades of your life how about we make
it a masterpiece step number two is
decide what needs to change you want to
make that Masterpiece of a life happen
awesome one needs to change who do you
need to become what are the habits that
you need to do the people that you look
up to respect admire who've done what
you want to do who came from Morrison
where you came from they've gone off and
achieved what do they do what actions do
they take what skill sets did they learn
what mindset shifts do they need to make
inside them who do they start hanging
out with right all of those what are the
habits what media did they consume what
books that they read all of it
understanding what you need to change
allows you to create a roadmap so you
want to build that beautiful life that
amazing life amazing what needs to
change now decide when needs to change
you may not even hate your life that's
even worse if you don't hate your life
it's harder to make growth if you
absolutely hate your life and say like
this sucks I'm moving on you've hit rock
bottom then it's actually very easy to
grow it's when when things are just good
you don't hate your life but it's good
it's good right your life is good you
have internet you have family it's good
but you know you're capable of more
that's what you need to push that's
where you need to decide what is an
amazing life look like what is what is a
masterpiece of a life look like for you
and write it out and look at it and get
emotional like I want that that must
happen
and if you're feeling that then what has
to change in you to go off and make that
happen decide today and step number
three is map your actions to your
Ambitions you say you want this you say
you want that Masterpiece of a life you
say you want to be here great
what are you gonna do every week what
are you going to do every day your
calendar dictates who you are success is
habits not some Final Destination so how
can you map your actions of what you're
doing in your calendar to your Ambitions
to become the person that you want to
become and Achieve what you want to
achieve
so if you've decided you've taken
responsibility for where you're at in
life and it's your your responsibility
to fix it and change it you've mapped
out what a great life looks like for you
great now break that down instead of
thinking 10 20 years out what are you
going to do today what are you gonna do
this week pull out your calendar from
Sunday to Sunday and map out where
you're going to be spending your time
and then step above it and look at it
and say if I did these things for the
week if I did those things will I move
closer to building that life that I want
and if it's a yes amazing do it and with
no then go fix it then all you have to
do is get up every day and do the work
rule number four treasure ideas the
reason most people don't win isn't
because you don't have great ideas
you're a genius the only thing missing
is momentum you're dreaming huge that's
amazing I love it but there is zero
momentum it's never going to be the
right time and nobody is coming to save
you the time is now to make your dreams
happen so here's a really fun example
yesterday I needed to take a break from
on my work to go to the bathroom so I go
to the bathroom open up my Feedly and
start looking at you know some of the
news stories that were happening and
there was this amazing video that I saw
about a busker in Toronto who a company
organized what they call the cash mob
instead of a flash mob where they would
all show up at this guy doing his you
know guitar singing playing and just
throw money at him not at him but in the
guitar case right and they were they
probably made like a thousand bucks
they're throwing 20s and 50s Not Just
pennies and and you know dollar bills
and stuff but give him tons of money and
and it and he's starting to get
overwhelmed he's playing the guitar he's
getting overwhelmed and and I'm I'm
getting motivated and excited and just
heartfelt what a great moment and I
decide in that moment we need to make
this video more public we need to spread
it this has to go up on the channel I
need to spread awareness I want to I
want to promote this company who put
this together I love it what a great
idea and so right away like here's the
thing you get a great idea trust your
great ideas go do something about it I
could have easily filed that away next
week I'll work on it and then what guess
what's gonna happen next week I'm not
gonna work on it because I'm going to
move on to something else right I'm in
the middle of my day I've got priorities
and a plan for that day and then this
thing pops up I trust that idea trust
that it's great and that I gotta do
something about it because if I'm
inspired if you're inspired you're going
to create gold you're going to create
Magic
if you're not inspired then just keep
doing the work that you're doing
hopefully it's not depressing and
negative it's just you're creating it's
amazing you're in your flow but when
something new comes up that you're super
excited about I think you need to follow
that through and so I I parked a little
chunk of my day yesterday to then make
that video and I made the ending and I
made the thumbnail and I made the
description and I made the title and I
created it all in one shot and I sent it
off to my editor Christina we love you
Christina say hey we got to put this up
on the channel find the time this is not
scheduled in my usual content calendar
but let's find a time put it up right
and that maybe took I don't know half an
hour
it took half an hour out of my day that
I was supposed to do other stuff to make
that happen because momentum matters
momentum matters it's the most important
thing you're a genius the ideas that you
have are goal they're genius you're just
not doing enough with it
I'm working on my tour right now
and this the most upset I've been in a
while I'm working on my tour and we're
supposed to follow up uh on reach out to
media and influencers and people in
different cities that I'm going to so
you know Cleveland Cincinnati my first
two stops I don't know a lot of people
in Cleveland Cincinnati and so trying to
figure out while I'm there what's the
best use of my time whose show can I be
on what media can I be on right whether
it's a YouTube show or a podcast or big
media and so we made a list of all this
is we're going to and I assigned it to
someone on my team to say okay we need
to research who's in each City and I I
just looked at it this week and and it
hasn't been done yet nothing no momentum
no progress you know not intentional
probably you know she's busy with doing
other stuff but I looked at the list
today it's like it's been a week it's
one week today I signed this one week
today and there's nothing that happened
on that list
like
apart from from
stealing or doing something unethical no
momentum is the worst it is like I can
handle you spending 20 hours going down
the wrong direction and making a whole
bunch of mistakes because I expect to
make mistakes as we go fast but zero
momentum drives me nuts like this is not
acceptable like as soon as we decide
something when do we start what do you
mean when do we start we start right now
ASAP you gotta sign something when now
what else are we doing it right like
momentum has to happen and this is the
problem because there's so many good
reasons why you can't do it now why you
shouldn't do it now great go do it now
all those reasons are logical they're
smart they make sense but to get in the
way of you actually accomplishing your
goals because the ideas that you have
are gold so how do you actually start
building some momentum I'm gonna give
you a three-step process that I think
will help step number one is think big
act small think big
act small big idea big Vision big dream
you want to change the world you're an
entrepreneur that's why you're watching
this channel I love you that's the best
that's amazing and act small what's the
smallest possible way to just get
started you want to build a YouTube
channel great use your phone pick it up
press record upload you want to start a
podcast awesome I had a guy come to my
workshop last week in Toronto
did I once set a podcast so I made I
listened to you and I just made my first
episode off my phone and it was me
talking for three minutes as to what I'm
gonna do my podcast okay guys I'm I'm
starting a new podcast I don't know what
I'm gonna do yet but I'm I'm
experimenting my podcast is basically
about how to overcome your your fear of
failing and so I'm afraid even in this
I'm afraid right now but this is the
starting point and as I do more I'll get
better and keep releasing episodes and I
hope you'll follow me on the journey
great like something like that great
post there's your first episode done
next
right will that blow up probably not
that's okay don't worry about blowing up
stop trying to be perfect your perfect
plan isn't going anywhere your perfect
plan is the death of momentum that's the
problem you're trying to be perfect the
beginning is not perfect the beginning
is messy it's supposed to be messy
because you don't know what you're doing
yet that's amazing that's awesome go
create creation is messy it's supposed
to be
right if it's perfect then you already
know what you're doing if you're living
perfect then you're only inside your
comfort zone because you've done it so
many times that's boring you don't want
perfect
create so you think big amazing and then
what's the smallest possible thing you
can do right now today make a video
record your podcast send an email call
somebody book a meeting something
something momentum teach yourself that
as soon as you get an idea a big idea
you find a way to just get started and
act small step number two is everyday
momentum everyday momentum you will
never accomplish your big thing if
you're only doing it once a month
you just won't I say you have Michael
Jordan level Talent at something Jordan
was not in the gym once a month
practicing it was every day every day
every day on my Channel videos go up how
did I you know blow up my YouTube
channel
when I'm when I'm introvert and shy and
scary in front of the camera and you
know all that stuff I'm making videos
every day right 6 000 videos later here
we are and I'm still working on getting
better I'm still at work in progress but
I'm way better than I was before because
I built momentum people with a lot more
Talent than me
I crossed I I passed them and growth in
momentum because I just kept making
stuff where they stopped or they they
slowed back right and and it it honestly
it bothers me it's part of my mission I
look at people that I passed I look at
guys I love I look at Tony Robbins they
look at Eric Thomas to look at amazing
speakers people I think are way better
than me at speaking and and I've passed
them because they just don't make as
much content
and now YouTube isn't their only game
Tony's got tons of businesses yes
amazing but at the same time you have
this gift you have this ability to reach
so many people it bothers me that that
uh that I'm ahead you should be you
should be crushing it and so every
single day you want to get great at your
thing every single day every single day
every single day practice release create
if you practice something that you loved
every day from today until you know the
end of one year from one year from now
you can be great at it if you love it
and you practice every day you will get
great at it your life will be totally
different
your business will be totally different
your relationships are totally different
everything will be totally different for
the better better bigger more impact
more love more joy more happiness more
fulfillment because you're doing the
thing every day and what started off is
finding 20 minutes a day to practice may
seem impossible and then you find the 20
minutes and then you do it for 20
minutes and then you start getting
better and then that 20 becomes 40 it
becomes 60 becomes 80. it becomes a
business now you're getting paid now you
can hire a team now you can keep growing
but it starts with you every single day
building momentum for your business and
step number three is expect to suck at
the beginning this is what hurts so many
people you expect to be great at the
beginning why do you expect to be great
at the beginning you think Jordan just
stepped up to the three-point line and
just sunk one at the start
you're supposed to suck at the start
doesn't mean you suck as a person as a
human but you're supposed to not how do
you think you're gonna have the skill
set when you've never done it before
the quantity leads to the Quality create
quality work yes great but how do you
create quality work by doing by
practicing by doing it every single day
so expect to suck reduce the burden on
yourself to create something amazing to
create a masterpiece the first time out
it's going to be brutal it's gonna suck
that's amazing it's why I kept all my
videos up on my channel you can go back
on my channel April 2009 was the first
video that I uploaded go back and watch
it it's still there
to show the journey it sucked like I
looked back and it's cringe-worthy I'm
embarrassed I'm nervous I'm shy like I
don't want to watch that video
but it shows the whole journey of how I
progressed
I sected beginning everybody sucked at
the beginning you will suck at the
beginning it's okay it's normal it's
natural it's amazing let's go rule
number five the last one before our very
special bonus
bonus as a tool most people grew up with
an unhealthy view of money some people
think that money is everything that the
next person you see the next customer
you talk to that's your next suit that's
your next car and other people think
that money is the root of all
right or the love of money is the root
of all
evil right to make money you're evil
you're slimy you're gross you're ripping
people off most people grow up in one of
those two camps that's the lesson that's
been taught you by your parents the
truth is money is just a tool money is
an amazing tool that lets you accomplish
amazing things and if you are an
entrepreneur and want to have success
making money has to be in your top five
list of priorities if it is not in your
top five then you're not making money
but it can't be number one money can't
be your number one priority there has to
be something that is more important than
it and that's your purpose I don't
really usually talk a lot about money on
my videos
um maybe I should maybe I should talk
more about it I think it's important I
think there's just so much out there
that seems to be money money money money
that I'm trying to go against it to say
like purpose is number one you have
you're built to serve if you're just
chasing money you're never gonna win I
think I see too many entrepreneurs just
chasing money and so a lot of the
content that I make is more Purpose
Driven but there's still there's still I
think a lot of people who are Purpose
Driven who've started the business for
the right reasons and they don't know
how to make money and so maybe I need to
switch up some of the content that I
make as well to help change the
perspective of our money my personal
view is I hate spending money till I'm
making money
I love making money it's not number one
right serving believing entrepreneurs is
number one but again it's in the top
five because if I didn't make money I
wouldn't have a team I wouldn't have
people to help me make this video it'd
be me by myself trying to put together
one piece of content you know a week or
maybe a day just you know filming by
myself but instead I have this team of
people who I'm super appreciative of and
I can afford that because I'm making
money doing the business that I'm doing
right kind of important when I look at
Jeremy who
I invest into earlier this year this is
this is a great example of how I like to
think right so Jeremy runs a YouTube
Consulting business I invested into him
I had this dream in the desert I'm
driving through the desert on my tour in
March
ish February around there this year 2019
and I have this idea that Jeremy I want
to start a YouTube Consulting business
with Jeremy at the time Jeremy was
working at a grocery store stocking
shelves and checking people out uh he
asked me a bunch of times whether he
could help me in any way if you could
walk my dog or buy groceries or like
anything just to just to help and I'm
like I don't need a I don't need
somebody to wash my car or walk my dogs
and so you know I said no but I love his
hustle and energy and drive and just
personality and I thought he'd make a
great entrepreneur and he's capable of
so much more than just working at a
grocery store
and so I had this dream in the desert
for some reason without a dream I was
driving so I was fully awake I told Nina
we need to get Jeremy on the line right
now
uh I had this idea so she messaged him
on Facebook and I said I need to talk to
him right now and at first he wasn't
available and said like you got to get
him on the on the Facebook live right
now like I need to talk to him on the
video right now
because if I waited till tomorrow I
would have I would have pushed it off
right I got an inspired idea let's go
and I said here's this idea I've got I
want to teach you YouTube I wanna I
wanna have you learn everything that I
know about it and I wanted to start a
YouTube Consulting business with you
and here's what you need to do are you
aware and he said yeah I'm in I want to
do it he didn't really know a ton about
YouTube at that point in time besides
coming to my thought Leadership Academy
the the I guess the couple months before
and I said okay before I come back I'm
gonna be home in two months here's what
you need to learn you need to watch all
of these videos where I talked about
YouTube you need to watch these other
channels and talk about YouTube you need
to analyze data you need to come up with
suggestions and feedback and you need to
know what you when I come home I was 90
days on the road when I come home you
have to learn and know and understand it
you got to be an expert
and he's great at learning so I thought
he would crush it where I thought he
might struggle is on the interaction and
talking to clients because he hadn't
done that work before so when I got home
the first step was
you're gonna you're gonna hop on a free
call you're gonna get some free advice
to people who've come to the thought
Leadership Academy and do YouTube audits
on them uh tell them you're going to
record the call and then I'm going to
listen in with you afterwards and he did
a great job
it I knew he'd be prepared and have the
research and know what he's doing
because he he studies and he works like
nobody else but I didn't know he'd do so
well and actually being able to handle
the objections and handle the the push
and the movement to help them and he's
only gotten better with time too but
this is listen this is since we started
the business together in April
and he's already building a six-figure
business
from a guy who went from stocking
shelves so now we're talking about how
do we scale it up Beyond him he can only
max out a certain amount of clients and
still you know serve them properly uh do
we bring on somebody else underneath
them and just keep increasing the prices
what kind of business that he want to
build
six figure business you know inside of
five months it's crazy right I mean
maybe not so crazy but from an idea to
action but didn't spend any money to
start it there were no ads that were
taken out is just research hard work
hustle Outreach
telling people he can help them and it
was him reaching out to people who
thought could really benefit that he had
knowledge I could help them and saying
I'd love to set up a free call with him
and he set up these half an hour calls
we was walking through and giving them
advice and he had three big ideas for
each client and and most people wouldn't
then hire him like most people who come
on a call you're not they're not going
to hire you right away
um but you hit a certain percentage
right and you get better in targeting
who you're going to go after and reach
and so now we've built a six-figure
business and plus now we're looking at
really scaling up for next year
and so
having this conversation I guess around
money I had to build a business quickly
without having to spend money
um I think is important and so maybe
I'll try to include more of that content
love to know your thoughts uh that can
be the question of the day let me know
your thoughts if you want more content
about making money uh on the channel you
can let me know in the comments below
but I'm going to give you a three-step
process that I think will help you step
number one is don't start spending money
until you're making it don't spend money
until you're making it so easy to spend
money this is the thing when I was in
Venture Capital raising money for
companies
everybody just showed how they're going
to spend money but not how they're going
to make it right it's so easy to think
about if I only had ten thousand dollars
fifty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars whatever you can go buy
all this stuff stop thinking about the
money you don't have right instead you
think about what you can do with what
you do have
what can you use your Genius you're
resourceful you've got ideas how do you
use that creativity instead of thinking
the biggest problem is money the problem
is not money the problem is you're not
resourceful enough go off and solve that
problem right Jeremy had a budget of
zero and still has a budget of zero to
build his business
and even if you're doing a product right
you say well he's doing a service great
maybe you actually start as a service
maybe your product ID should start as a
service to get close to your customers
and build a reliable repeatable income
stream but if you're going to do a
product you pre-sell right you pre-sell
you you make a you make a mock-up and if
you can't actually make like a mug to
show then you make a design of it right
you do a mock-up there's always a
smaller way to get started and you
pre-sell you're not putting enough
hustle energy heart dedication into it
and you're blaming lack of money too
many people maybe not you but too many
people that's the problem don't spend
money until you're making money it's a
great will to start by number two is
study wealthy people who share the same
values as you this is this is where it
becomes particularly difficult because
you might look at some people who have
money who've made it and say well that
person is such a whatever right that
person is is evil or that person is
whatever like you come up with a story
in your mind and so even if you're
looking at YouTube whether you're
looking at my content or Gary or Grant
or Tom or Patrick or any of the Mel any
of the people creating content think
about first who do you resonate with on
values right maybe you love Gary and
hate grants or maybe you love Grant and
you hate Gary maybe you love Dan and
hate Evan right great awesome
go learn from that person go learn from
that person because the way that they
think about money could be the thing
that you need the most and so surround
yourself with them watch their videos
read their books go to their events to
see that somebody who has the same
values as you can make money so that's
possible so don't so that you don't feel
like I'm a nice guy or a nice girl and I
can never make money because I want to
rip people off there's lots of people
who are making lots of money and not
ripping people off so find your
favorites and model them and be around
them and surround yourself with them if
if only virtually like even if you never
meet them if only virtually so that
their way of thinking their thought
process and money starts to seep into
you and step number three is understand
that money lets you serve the more money
you have the more you can serve right
what happens if you're not making money
then this thing that you love doing this
is what this part the last section built
to serve if you guys don't have built
the serve you can pre-order in the link
below the last section I built to serve
the whole the first part is all about
finding your purpose right you were
built to serve how are you built to
serve the process is in here right
um the last section though is how to
turn it into a business because if you
found your call and if you found the
thing that is your purpose that you want
to do for the rest of your life but you
can't turn it into something that's
going to pay you the problem is you're
just doing it as a hobby for the rest of
your life and and there's nothing
necessarily wrong with that you're still
helping you're still giving you're still
contributing but you can only do it on
the evenings and weekends because you're
not making enough money to actually
support yourself so you have to have
this job that you know maybe you hate
maybe you don't hate but isn't actually
your thing and then when you get home
the last couple hours of the weekends
those hours you can use to fulfill your
purpose and that's great and that's
Noble but what if you could turn your
full-time thing into the thing that
fulfills your purpose so that one you're
happier because you're doing more work
on on the thing that you love doing
right but then two you can scale it up
you can hire people now and now instead
of just you part-time fulfilling your
purpose you have yourself and a whole
team of people of 10 100 a thousand
people all contributing towards your
mission which then allows you to give
right at every event that I do there's
always
usually aim for ten percent
um of people who who are in for free who
couldn't afford it
all right so on my tour when we go on
the workshop and the tour
um we're doing 20 something cities over
almost 90 days
ten percent of the room will be free
because they can't afford it because
maybe they're homeless you wouldn't know
it because a lot of people are homeless
that you would not know are homeless
right uh whenever I do my thought
Leadership Academy in Toronto it's a
it's a I don't know I forget what the
ticket is a couple thousand to come
um there's always somebody in the room
who's there on basically a sponsorship
right it's a it's a I'm gonna say
donation it's uh what when you give to
education I don't know anyway
we let somebody in for free somebody who
can't afford it somebody who I believe
in who I think has a message and and
will take a lot from this training and
they get in for free and because I'm
making money that allows me to do that
if if I wasn't getting paid at all from
any of the people who come out then I
couldn't just do it all for free every
time because then I can't afford a
location I can't afford to have my team
members I couldn't be able to put it
together so understanding making that
shift in your head that money allows you
to serve the more money you make the
more you can serve the more you can help
people and if you actually want to
fulfill your purpose then you have to
learn how to make money in your business
most people suck at creating work-life
balance or Harmony because you're
constantly comparing what you're doing
to other people's schedules of all the
things that you need to figure out in
life what balance means to you is among
the most important Jeff Bezos jokes
about optimizing his toothbrushing
routine because he's trying to maximize
his efficiency while Warren Buffett
reads for five to six hours every day
you can't do both and you need to stop
comparing yourself to someone who you're
not it's crazy how much balance and
scheduling comes up I think most people
are lost I think I think again the
biggest problem is you're just comparing
yourself to other people and then you
don't know where to stand you don't know
what rock to stand on until you feel
like you're pulled in a thousand
different directions when I went on my
tour this year and I'm sure it's going
to come up on the next one again people
kept asking that what does balance mean
to you how do I find balance in my life
and I used to joke one of the funniest
jokes that I told and I'm not that funny
so this is this is one of the funny
moments wasn't was talking about the
Rock and The Rock has his routine where
he's working out for four hours a day he
has to work out for four hours a day and
so when he's doing his movies he wakes
up five hours before he has to be on set
and he'll work out for his four hours
and he'll do two times cardio and two
times weights and then go to the you
know go to his trailer shower and then
head head out to the movies and he's
only sleeping four to five hours at
night when he's on set
I think that's crazy but I don't look
like the Rock and that's when people
would laugh because I don't look like
the rock but it's true people will try
to take on the Rock schedule but you
have other priorities
what the Rock values isn't the same
thing as you value there may be some
overlap and some similarities and
there's nothing wrong with trying on the
hat there's nothing wrong with
attempting to do it there's nothing
wrong with seeing how it fits right to
get pieces to say hey I'm going to try
meditating I'm going to try working out
I'm going to try making a video I'm
going to try morning Pages I'm gonna
awesome great yes
but then to judge yourself to say well
I'm not able to stay consistent on that
it's not what you should be doing
because you want to work out four hours
a day and you want to read five hours a
day like Warren Buffett and you want to
optimize your toothbrush routine like
Jeff Bezos and you want to do all these
different things but it's too many hours
in a day what you have to figure out is
how does balance look like for you and
then not be ashamed to go off and live
it when everybody else thinks you're
nuts so how do you do it I'm gonna give
you a three-step process that I think
will help step number one is start to
figure out what does balanced Harmony
look like for you whatever you want to
call it sit down take some time book off
half the day this is worth it this is
worth it if it's a Saturday afternoon or
Sunday morning whenever you are the most
freeing creative find a space that you
love whether it's walking out of nature
or or you know your desk at home or a
coffee shop Library something where you
can just be by yourself not have
distractions and really just ask
yourself what does a balanced life look
like for you what does harmony look like
for you because you don't want to spend
all day at work you don't and you don't
want to spend all day with your family
either you don't you don't want to spend
all day doing anything but what's that
ratio look like you don't spend all day
sleeping what's that ratio between how
much time sleeping how much time with
your family how much time on your
hobbies how much time with your friends
how much time at work what does that
ratio look like for you and you may get
a weird duck answer like it may not fit
into the society's Norms that's okay
right it starts with you understanding
this is what I need for my life having
in Clarity and having certainty around
it so that when other people judge you
for your crazy schedule say this is what
I need this is what I need remember the
people who are judging you are all
insecure about their own life and their
own schedule too so don't worry about it
go live your life spend the half day
maybe do it right now if you have some
ideas already what does balance or
Harmony look like for you number two is
map your actions to your missions okay
great now that you've set out what a
what a perfectly Balanced Life looks
like for you what you gotta do it
you show me your calendar where you're
actually doing it I live my life by
different days so Monday is my mentoring
day Tuesday is my YouTube day Wednesday
is my project day Thursday is my public
facing day Friday is my CEO day Saturday
is fun day with the family and Sunday is
family at midday Costco and shopping and
groceries and laundry and all that stuff
right and that's how most of the time I
live my life when I'm on tour when I'm
doing trips or something speaking then
it gets a little bit more chaotic but
then it returns back to normal because
that's what balance Harmony looks like
for me that may be crazy for you that
may be crazy for you if you look at my
Thursdays it's back to back to back
meetings I might have I might have 10 or
15 meetings back to back to back to back
to back with like two three four minute
breaks in between that's it all day long
from nine in the morning until sometimes
11 at night I love it it's great and
then on Wednesday look at my calendar
it's open nothing
white space to work on whatever I want
to work on because if I'm doing my book
or I'm working on my course or I'm doing
some creative work
I like having the entire day wide open
for me to do it so I don't book meetings
on a Wednesday I don't talk to my team
on a Wednesday I don't make videos on a
Wednesday I do my project work on a
Wednesday right that's what I love doing
and so that works for me that may be the
worst thing of all time for you awesome
but my actions map to my ambitions
if I set out what does bounce look like
for me this is it I'm living it just
like Saturday is fun day don't message
me on a Saturday you're not going to get
a response I'm spending the day with my
wife I'm planning surprises per I'm
taking to a new restaurant we're
planning some kind of activities to do
together so we do on Saturdays right
that's my version of balance but at the
same time during the week
my wife and I we work together so I see
her a lot but we don't start hanging out
at night until eight o'clock
right that may seem crazy for you but
then we have all of Saturday completely
shut down to work on things together fun
things and then Sunday the whole day to
do what is actually family work right
that works for us it works for me it
works for her it works for us it may be
the worst thing of all time for you
maybe you do want to spend three hours a
day cuddling with your husband or wife
awesome put it in I'm not judging you
put it in go do it if that's what leads
you to be happy balance and you bring
the best of you everywhere you go then
you do it you created your version of
balance now you need to map your actions
to your Ambitions and put it in your
calendar and stick to it and then set
number three is follow the Quincy Jones
rule Quincy Jones legendary music
producer once said not one ounce of my
self-worth comes from your opinion of me
and I really love that because I think
so often we play small based off of
other people's opinions and expectations
of you all these other people with low
standards who hate their lives are
judging you and you now you live your
life by their low standards somebody who
hates their life right they're just on
the edge of depression or maybe they're
already there and they're judging you
and these are the people whose opinions
you care so much about
not one ounce of my self-worth comes
from your opinion of me that doesn't
have to be something you say out loud to
them that might cause some problems but
in your own head in your own head right
their opinion doesn't mean anything to
you if somebody looks at your calendar
and you're cuddling your husband away
for three hours a day and that's what
you need awesome embrace it this is who
I am I'm crushing it what are you doing
are you happy with your life right
follow the Quincy Jones rule
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome and if you
want to watch Evan's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue to believe
I will see you there what you believe
about yourself is you
much outside affirmations you get or
other people telling you that you're
amazing if you don't believe in your
heart that you are amazing